How's everyone doing?
[APPLAUSE]
Parents only, how are you doing?
How is it that the parents
were louder than the kids?
Kids, how are you guys doing?
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Welcome, parents.
I'm really excited to
have you here in class.
This is 3091, Introduction
to Solid State Chemistry.
And today we're going to
have a little bit of fun.
As you can see, we
got some activities.
Now, the way I like
to frame this--
are there any other seats?
No, not so much.
But make yourself comfortable.
The way I like to
frame this is you've
got a lot of activities
going on already.
This is the parent weekend.
So if we look at--
why is that happening?
If we look at the--
oh, that's not good.
OK, there we go.
If we look at the MIT family
weekend, there is activities.
And so what I
thought is that what
we could do in this class--
we've got to learn a little bit.
We're going to learn
about x-rays today.
But what I thought
we could do is also
add some ideas for
activities that you all
could do with your kids.
But it doesn't even matter.
It could be with any kids.
But just more activities to
do to give you more options.
And so in particular, I've
got five suggestions for you
that we'll talk about today.
The first one is staying warm.
It's gotten really
cold, so we're
going to talk
about staying warm.
And then the next
thing we'll do is
we'll appreciate the
fall and all the colors.
And we'll cook.
Cooking is such a
wonderful thing to do.
I hope you guys
can do it together.
We'll talk about that.
And we'll talk about phones and
how they crack their screens.
And we have some sort
of larger versions
here that we'll talk about.
And of course, it
wouldn't be complete
if we didn't blow
bubbles, because that's
a really fun activity no
matter what age you are.
So that's our plan.
That's our plan today.
Now let's get started.
So let's start with
the first activity,
and it's staying warm.
So I love candles, and I think
a lot of us have seen candles.
The difference is between
everyone else's and your kids
who are in this
class who see candles
is they don't see candles.
They see C25 H52 combusting.
And your kids now, when
they see a candle--
if you guys go out to dinner and
there's a candle on the table,
the first thing--
I guarantee you the
first thing they're
going to do is assess
the volume of the room,
figure out how much oxygen in
grams there is in that room,
and they're going
to decide which
one is the limiting
reagent, the candle or you.
And they'll make a choice.
They may get you out of the
room because you don't know.
You've got to know that.
And of course, they'll have
their periodic tables with them
at the dinner.
Don't be surprised
when they take it out.
Now, your students-- oh,
yeah, that's perfect.
Your students also know--
your kids, my
students, your kids--
also know that a lot of the
earliest chemistry, going
all the way back to the times
of Democritus thousands of years
ago, the way it started
was because people
were breaking things and
smashing things and lighting
stuff on fire.
And we've got the whole
periodic table in this class,
but we still know that the most
fun element of all to light
on fire is the very first.
It's hydrogen.
And so I thought I would
show you what that's like.
OK.
So here's hydrogen.
And like I said, this is also--
it's a way to think about--
oh, that's a beautiful thing.
Is that a beautiful thing?
I've got to do it again.
And as your kids know,
I can do this a lot.
But it's just-- and
my hand doesn't--
I don't feel it because
of the heat capacity.
But that's another class.
But what we're interested
in is combustion.
So there's that one there, too.
So this is all about the context
of staying warm, of course.
You don't need to light
hydrogen on fire to stay warm.
But I also have suggested
discussion topics.
Because I don't want you
just to do these activities.
I want you to be engaged.
It might have been a while
since you guys have connected--
I don't know-- in person.
And so here, maybe you don't
know what to say at first.
And so for example, you could
talk about balancing chemical
reactions.
You could talk about
the concept of a mole.
And you could also
talk about limiting
reagents, which are really,
really important in life.
So that's my first
suggested activity.
Like I said, we'll have
five new activities.
That's the first one.
But like I also said, we've
got to learn something today.
And students, this is not
on the exam, as a reminder.
But we do need to
learn what X-rays are.
Because next week, we're going
to be shining them on stuff.
So today, we're going to learn
about how X-rays are generated.
And it all starts with
the very first selfie.
This is it.
Does anybody know who that is?
That is Anna Rontgen. That is
the wife of Wilhelm Ronten.
That's the very first
X-ray ever taken.
And Wilhelm Rontgen was playing
around with cathode ray tubes.
And so he--
I love this quote of him.
He said, I did not think.
I investigated.
And that's-- now, we think.
Of course we think.
But what we do in this
class is we investigate.
We're explorers.
Were explorers of
chemistry and how chemistry
connects to what we see in life
and what we're doing every day.
And so how did Rontgen do this?
OK.
Well, literally, it was a dark
and stormy night, literally.
And he was in the
basement in his lab.
That's him.
And it's going to be stormy
tomorrow, so you guys could
even try to think about how
it felt. And so what he did
is he--
everybody was playing with
these cathode ray tubes.
We learned a lot about
cathode ray tubes.
So here, you put some
kind of cathode here.
And then there is an anode
here, and you hook it up
to a voltage.
And what happens
is electrons fly.
This is a cathode ray
tube, so it's the CRT.
Electrons will fly off of
the cathode and go here.
Now, if they go
through the anode,
and then you put a
screen here, those
are the very first cathode
ray tube experiments.
And we talked about how
this led to the discovery
of the electron itself.
But what Rontgen did is
he said, now, hold on.
What if I changed--
I put a voltage here.
What if I amp that up?
What if I just keep going?
Oh, by the way, there is
a vacuum inside of here.
There has to be a vacuum.
And if I am the voltage
up-- you know what?
Actually, I'm going to put
a metal here for the anode.
I'm going to make that
some kind of metal,
and I'm going to hit the
metal with the electrons.
Now, this is exactly
what happened.
What happened is
the room glowed.
The room glowed.
So Rontgen had-- showing you
there, the lights are off.
The lights are off,
but the room was lit.
And he said, oh my goodness.
What is going on here?
What is going on?
And what he decided--
he literally
discovered a new type
of ray, a new type of light ray.
And because he didn't
know what to call it--
he didn't have a name on
that dark and stormy night--
he wrote down the letter x,
which he regretted later.
He really did.
Because everybody
started calling it--
he didn't know what to
call it, so he called it
an X-ray, which is
what happens when
you do this experiment
with a very high voltage.
You get rays that came off of
this and illuminated the room.
And he said, I don't
know what to call it.
I'll put the letter x for now.
And that stuck.
Now, these X-rays are unique.
They're unique because
they have very high energy.
They have very high energy.
So the X-ray energies--
the energies are in the
range of 100 eV to 100 KeV.
That's a big energy.
But we know how to
go back and forth
between energy and wavelengths.
So we know that that means
that the wavelength range is
between 0.01 and 10 nanometers.
And that's what's
really important.
You came up with a source that
has wavelengths in this very,
very special regime.
This is a very special
regime because it's
the distance between atoms.
Now, there's two
types of x-rays.
But first, let's-- at the
time, you might think, people--
why wasn't he wearing
anything, like at the dentist?
Why wasn't he wearing anything?
They didn't know that
radiation could be dangerous.
And so if you look
at the time, there
were ads like this for a
system to remove the hair.
And it was advertised as
effective, safe, and painless.
This is-- those are X-rays, one
of the first uses of X-rays.
This is a token to
get into a bath that's
called a radium bath.
It's a water bath where you have
radium that you either drink
or is in the water itself.
And look at what was
happening in Paris.
Radium cure, a fad
of Paris society.
Patients play bridge and take
tea for two hours daily--
daily-- in a drawing room.
This is what it says.
December 9th.
The afternoon radium cue is the
latest craze in Paris society.
The popularity of the
treatment, new to Paris,
has devolved quite suddenly and
is due, no doubt, to the fact
that it is exceedingly pleasant.
Oh, France.
Right?
They didn't know.
And it was the same
with these X-rays.
What is this thing?
Well, it turned out it was
a very, very important type
of light.
And because of its
importance, Ronten
won the first ever Nobel
Prize given in physics.
There is an element, number
111, named Roentgenium.
And 60 years later, the
DNA was discovered--
the structure of the
DNA, the double helix
was discovered
because of X-rays.
So the impact of
X-rays is tremendous.
Now, the next activity,
as I mentioned,
has to do with
enjoying the fall.
Now, the thing is that New
England has beautiful colors.
And so if you haven't taken
a stroll around the parks,
or maybe you go up
to a nice hike--
you'll see these beautiful
colors changing in the leaves.
But the thing is that
in our class, your kids,
they don't see that anymore.
No.
They don't.
Because when they
see colors, they
think about electron levels.
That's what they think about.
They can't help it.
They cannot help it.
So when they see orange or
red, all they're thinking about
is, oh, my goodness, there
is an electron level here,
and an electron getting excited,
and it's coming back down
and emitting a photon, and
how those levels are changing
as you go from one
leaf to another,
and how chemistry is
at the heart of it all.
Chemistry is at the
heart of it all.
And so that's what
they're thinking of.
And we can use chemistry.
I don't know if we have
the next one ready here.
We can use chemistry not only to
change the levels of electrons
that are in this material, which
then changes the color of light
that comes off of it--
it's all about the electrons--
but we can use
chemistry to control
how quickly that happens.
Nature does it on this
yearly time scale.
We can do it on any time scale
because of chemical kinetics.
So we're going to get
that experiment out here
in a second.
Meanwhile-- oh, there it is.
Can we give the
helpers a huge hand?
Because they are--
thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Now what do I do?
And that's it?
This is pre-mixed?
Oh.
OK.
Now, this is an example
of how we can change--
we can control the color of
a material using chemistry.
We can control when--
do I pour it all?
Do I pour it all?
OK.
Why not?
Yeah.
OK.
Now I want you to focus
on the larger bottle.
Nothing is happening.
Keep watching it.
You've got to keep watching it.
See?
That's an example.
But your students, your kids are
seeing this and they're saying,
no, it's all about
electron levels.
I've got to go and write
down those electron levels.
I don't care if it's a Bohr
model or a semiconductor
bandgap.
I've got to figure
out how that happened.
How did the color change?
I changed the electron
levels in the liquid.
That's what I did.
And I controlled the kinetics.
So my suggested topics for
this one of discussion--
chemical kinetics.
Now, we're going to talk
about chemical kinetics
later in the fall,
but you guys can
get a head start this weekend.
Because that's what
happened there.
We controlled when it-- it
didn't happen right away.
It happened later.
Why?
Acids and bases, also coming
later, get a head start.
And then how to
paint with electrons,
because that is
what we're doing.
We're changing how electrons
interact with the material
to change the color.
We are painting.
And that's what nature
is doing with its leaves.
Now, you might be on
this walk, and you
might be strolling
around, and you might not
go into the countryside.
You might just be
down Mass Ave. Now,
if you're walking down
Mass Ave from here,
and you go not towards
Boston but the other way,
you get to another school.
Now, I've got to--
I have talked to your
kids about this already.
What I want to do right
now is address the parents.
You have activities
you're going to, right?
And some of them may involve--
I don't know, a
dinner or a party,
or a lot of other parents.
Some of those
parents may have kids
that go to the other school.
Now, here's what I
want to tell you.
It might not be their fault.
I'm just saying we do the
best we can as parents.
We do.
We do everything we can.
We did everything right.
And then you realize
sometimes, kids
have to make their own mistakes.
So I just-- and the last
thing I'll say about this--
look, be nice, because
they're probably going
through a really hard time.
So that's what I want
to say about the stroll.
You might wind up down there.
I don't know.
OK, back to our X-rays.
Where were we?
So x-rays are coming
off of this metal.
It's super high voltage.
It's a a dark and stormy night.
What happened next
is that we had
to figure out what were the
properties of this light.
And what we really
mean are things
like intensity and wavelength.
Now, I wrote down ranges there.
But basically, what you have
with X-rays are two types.
You have type 1, which
is called continuous.
And it arises continuous--
continuous.
And it actually-- this
is a pretty good name,
because it's a continuous
energy up to a point.
It's a continuous spectrum.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, what I mean by
that-- to understand that,
we have to know how we get it.
There are two types of X-rays.
In this first type,
what we have is
we have some atoms with a
bunch of protons in there.
This is like that metal atom.
And I've shot really
high-energy electrons at it.
But that atom has electrons
sitting around it.
We know that.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
OK, and then again.
And these are the
quantum levels.
This would be n
equals 3, n equals 2.
And in here, we've
got n equals 1.
But now, here's the thing.
I'm shooting high-energy
electrons at this atom.
So one of the first things that
can happen is nothing at all.
So if I shoot it, say,
up here, way away--
if it's all the way up here
going way away from the atom
and doesn't feel it, then
it might just come through.
It might have some
energy-- call it e0--
and it just came
all the way through.
It didn't interact.
Well, that's kind of boring.
What if I interacted-- what if
I'm out here, and I interact--
I got through some of
those outer electrons.
Immediately, what do I see?
If I'm a negative charge,
I see this positive charge,
and I'm like, ah,
that looks good.
It's an attraction.
And so the electron
curves like that.
Now, that means
that it accelerated.
This is not a electron
stuck in an orbit.
No.
This one was free,
and it remained free.
But because it got inside of
the electron cloud of the atom,
it saw a a positive charge.
And that bends it, and
that accelerates it.
And when something that's
charged accelerates,
it gives off a photon.
It gives off a photon.
So that might be
some kind of energy
that it has left
over that we call e1.
And this would be
like the photon 1.
And we know that it's
lost energy to the photon.
It's decelerated.
So we know that e0
is greater than e1.
But I could have shot
another one through,
and this one got even luckier.
These are my electrons,
incoming electrons.
This one got even closer
to the positive charge,
felt an even
stronger attraction,
and decelerated even more.
And so it also emits a photon.
And so we know that e2
must be smaller than e1.
It's left with less energy.
Now, what you're doing is
you're decelerating electrons
by having them pass through
the cloud of charge of an atom.
And that deceleration
emits photons.
And you can see right
away what I'm doing
is I'm breaking the electrons.
Well, that's exactly what this
kind of radiation is called.
This radiation is, in fact,
called Bremsstrahlung.
And that literally
means braking radiation.
Braking radiation.
It means breaking.
Well, if I take this
very simple picture,
and I try to make a plot-- like
I said, if I want to understand
my light, I've got
to know about how
it behaves as a function of,
say, wavelength or frequency.
And so if you plotted the
wavelength with the intensity,
well, you can see right
here I'm going to get--
OK, so I'm going to
get some photon that
comes out that has
some lambda, and then
another photon that comes
out that has another lambda.
But you can see that that
electron could have been
braked at any loss of energy.
And so what you get is something
that is very continuous
up to a point.
This is the shape
that it looks like.
So I can get-- this is lambda.
So if lambda is out
there, this would
be like lower energy photons.
And up here, it's higher,
higher-energy photons.
Now, these are all x-rays.
They're in this very
high-energy range.
But you've got this
continuous spectrum.
Because the electron could
have been slowed down
in any way except
higher than this point.
Why?
Well, that's just determined
by how much energy
that initial electron got.
Because you can imagine this
point is a special point.
This represents a fully
stopped electron, fully braked,
fully stopped electron.
So that incoming electron has
transferred all of its energy
to the photon.
And because this
is higher energy,
that's as high as it gets.
That makes sense, right?
OK.
We have a name for that too.
That's the Duane Hunt limit.
And basically, it says
that the energy of--
the maximum energy, e max of
the photon that can come out
is equal to the electron
times the voltage, the charge
of the electron times
the voltage across, ev
across the tube, and that that
is equal to hc over lambda min.
This is just saying max
energy equals hc over min
wavelength, energy wavelength.
So that's one type.
And if I had--
but now you can see
if I shot it, now I'm
bumping up the
voltage even more,
and I'm shooting it with
higher-energy electrons.
Well, you can imagine that
if the electrons I shoot in
have a higher energy,
then that point is going
to go in and in like that.
So this would be
Bremsstrahlung radiation,
and this would be
increasing incident-- inc?
That's not good.
Incident electron energy.
And I will put a box around
this so that it's increasing,
that arrow going like that.
So if I shoot it with higher
and higher-energy electrons,
I'm still going to
have a minimum lambda,
but it's going to get
smaller and smaller.
Continuous x-rays.
OK.
That's type 1.
Now, speaking of breaking--
now, speaking of breaking--
OK.
Now, here is my third
activity, and it's cooking.
And I love cooking,
and I hope you do too.
It's a really fun thing to do.
And I think that I love
cooking with cast iron.
So maybe you've got a piece
of cast iron in your dorm
that you can pull out,
and pull out a recipe,
and start making something.
But what I want you
to think about--
and this is the
thing-- is your kids,
our students don't see
it as cast iron anymore.
They see it as iron with
interstitially doped carbon.
That's what they see it as.
And so I want you to
see it that way too.
And then that gets you thinking.
How is this cast iron so strong?
And oh, wait, the
early chemists--
I heard they smashed and
they lit things on fire.
How could we break
this cast iron?
Could it break?
Should we be worried about it?
And so what I think you should
do-- oh, yeah, there it is.
Let's take this.
You take the--
I don't have a pan,
but I have this.
Is this filled?
OK.
And you take out a
hammer because you
have a hammer in the closet.
And you go like this.
And nothing happens.
And then you do it again.
You say, well, you know what?
Maybe we need to
go a little bigger.
And you go into your closet,
and you find a sledgehammer.
And you say, you know what?
I think if we just use
this handy sledgehammer--
hopefully not in your dorm--
then maybe we'll break it.
And so you keep hitting--
not over the electrical.
And you hit it again.
And I won't use--
I won't go extreme here,
but I will tell you
that I've done it before.
And nothing happens.
Nothing happens.
There's not even
a scratch on it.
But these are your kids who
go to MIT, not another school.
And they know-- and they know
that intermolecular forces
have power.
They've got a lot of power.
And they know about bonding.
And they know about
the hydrogen bond,
and the power of the hydrogen
bond, and how strong it is,
and why it is.
And then they start
thinking about water.
I wonder if we could leverage
the power of the hydrogen bond.
Now, do we have liquid nitrogen?
We do.
OK.
So they put it
together that we might
be able to leverage that power
of the hydrogen. They knew.
They saw the gecko.
They say, the London dispersion
lets a gecko climb a wall.
Well, then hydrogen
bonds might be what it
takes to break the cast iron.
All that you need is to
pull the liquid nitrogen out
of your dorm closet, and--
yeah, OK.
You want to go ahead?
Yeah.
And fill it with
water because you
need to take advantage of the
power of the hydrogen bond.
And then let it sit, of
course with the blast shield
that you also have handy.
OK.
Well, let's see how this goes.
And we might take a--
we'll see what happens.
Again, this is a bonding moment.
This is a hydrogen
bonding moment.
But this is where
the two of you--
the three of you, the four of
you-- it could be a huge group.
This is where you talk about
things like the crystal
structure of iron.
This is where you
talk about things
like intermolecular forces.
And we've learned them all.
We learned about them
all in this class.
Where you talk about the power
bonds and the power of the bond
between you as a family.
This is it.
Just do it on this side
of the blast shield.
OK.
Now we'll let that sit.
We'll see how that goes.
And OK, yeah.
That's good.
Now, where were we?
Oh, right.
Oh, there's another
type of X-ray.
There's another type of X-ray.
And the other type of X-ray--
that's the only board left.
The other type of X-ray is from
a different phenomenon that
also has to do with--
it also has to do with
the atom and the electron.
Because the one type is because
the electrons are coming
through this cloud,
and they get a little
attracted, and they lose
energy, and they give that off
to an X-ray photon.
But see, the other kind comes
from a direct excitation,
the same kind that
we learned about when
we looked at the Bohr atom.
And so this is drawn here.
Now, there's a very
important thing that happens.
As we've learned
in this class, when
you go from one
area of expertise
to another-- like
crystallographers
don't like commas.
They don't like commas.
Don't upset a crystallographer.
It makes no sense.
It's not worth it.
This is the same thing
with X-ray specialists.
Don't use n equals 1,
n equals 2, n equals 3.
Use KLM, because
they prefer that.
So the KLMs there are
simply the quantum numbers,
the principle quantum numbers.
So 1 is k, 2 is l, and 3 is m.
And all we're doing is the
same kind of excitations
as drawn there very well.
So you see the incident
electron comes in,
and now it's got
enough energy to excite
one of those core electrons.
It's got enough
energy to excite it.
And so what it does is it trades
energy with that core electron.
The core electron goes up,
and then it comes back down.
Now, if we had,
say, an m level--
so this is n equals 1, 2, 3.
So if we had--
now I can draw it.
If I had some electron in my
k shell, my n equals 1 shell,
and that electron got bumped
up to an l shell, well,
now you know-- from our
work with the Bohr atom,
you know that when
this goes back down,
it's going to emit a photon.
But this is very different now.
This is very different.
This photon has only that
energy, nothing in between.
It's not continuous.
I'm getting used
to wearing this.
It feels good.
It feels pretty good.
So I could have
had an electron--
instead of going to the l level,
maybe it went all the way up
to the m level.
And then from there,
it cascades back down,
and it emits a photon.
And the way this works
in terms of labeling
is because it goes down to the
k level, these are k photons.
And we go in order.
So this is the least
energy k photon.
It ended in k.
So that's a k alpha or k--
I'll just write it out
to be clear-- k beta.
Oh, I hear sizzling.
Oh, that's because
you're pouring.
That's good.
More liquid nitrogen
is never a bad thing.
That's great.
No, no, I'm good.
You guys are doing such a good--
now, OK.
So if it's k beta-- because
it went to k, it ended at k.
It gave off a photon.
The photon is either
alpha, beta, gamma,
depending on which one.
But now here's the thing.
You know if you go back
to that plot of energy--
of lambda versus
intensity, well, you
know that there's
nothing in between.
There are no electronic
states in here.
So you can't excite in between.
This is forbidden.
It's forbidden.
So unlike the braking kind
of radiation, in this case,
it's very, very discrete.
And so now, if we plot
what you get from this,
well, you're going to get a k
alpha peak that's very, very
discrete, and you're going to
get a k beta peak that's only
at the one energy
that is the difference
between these levels,
k alpha k beta.
So that's another kind.
This is a type 2.
This is second type of X-ray.
OK.
It sounded interesting.
We'll let it keep going.
It's good because
it gives you a time.
And I hope-- you guys
can just leave it.
I hope that during this
time that you're here
doing these activities,
don't have your phones.
Put them down.
Listen to the sounds
of cast iron popping.
You can't appreciate it
if you're on your phone
tweeting it or DMing it.
You can't do that.
It's not going to happen.
It won't be as much of a bond.
Did I get it right?
No?
OK.
So we got our second type
of X-ray, and it's discreet.
And we're going to put
them together in a minute.
But first, we've got
to talk about glass.
Now-- oh, more.
OK.
Good.
Keep going.
Oh, glass.
That's perfect.
The thing is that--
well, a lot of times this
happens to your phone.
And we know about
crystals in this glass.
And this is the one--
if you were willing to pay
hundreds of dollars more
for your iWatch, you
can get a quartz screen.
This is quartz.
This is what we know now.
We don't look at the Apple ad.
We look at this in this class.
I'm good.
We're good.
Yeah, thank you.
And so we can hand
this out because we
like to touch and feel the
chemistry in this class.
That is quartz.
That's not glass, by the way.
And that's another thing
we're going to learn.
Glass means amorphous.
It means not crystalline.
That's the thing on the right.
Now, quartz has a lot of
really great properties.
It's a very strong material.
But it's a lot more expensive,
which is why this happens.
And you've got all this glass,
this amorphous SIO2 that is--
oh, that was a good one.
Yeah, I see water coming out.
But there are ways
to try to make
that stronger, to try to make
the amorphous SIO2 stronger.
And there's no better
way to think about--
and I don't want you
to break your phone.
But if you think--
speaking of phones--
if you think about
glass, you're probably
thinking about baseball.
And if you're thinking
about baseball,
you're thinking about
the Red Sox, of course.
Right?
Am I right?
And so I brought
glass, and I want
to think about how glass breaks.
That's what we're going to
study in a couple of weeks
in this class.
But I thought let's
bring this to life.
But I need some
volunteers, and I'd
like some parents to come down.
I need some baseball
arms, some people who
can throw this at the glass.
It's OK.
Come on.
I need some volunteers.
Come on down.
There you go.
You don't look quite like
a parent, but it's OK.
All right.
OK.
Now, OK.
We need to get-- let's get
you a little further back.
And we're going to
have you put this on.
This is for aim.
And what I want
you to try to do is
throw this as hard as you
can at that piece of glass
on the left.
Can you do that?
All right.
Really let it go.
Now, hold on.
Hold on.
Let's move you right over here.
The one on the left right
there as hard as you can.
OK, that's all right.
Try it again.
We get multiple tries here.
We'll take turns.
OK.
Try again.
That was good.
I think we need to
try a little harder.
One more time, and
then we'll get--
what parent?
That's the annealed
one, isn't it?
Last year it didn't
break, either.
Thank you very much.
Who's next?
I need a volunteer.
Come on down.
Oh, you look too
happy not to try.
You look too happy not to try.
Can you hand those to
this gentleman right here?
All right.
Come on down.
Now, we're going after that
piece of glass on the left.
And we're going to see if
it's a good piece of glass
for your phone.
OK?
All right.
Let's let it rip.
Oh, yeah.
That's all right.
Try again.
Multiple tries.
You've got this.
Oh.
That's very strong glass.
Try one more time.
Really?
OK.
Let's try the one
on the right there.
Let's see if that one breaks.
We might have them reversed.
We don't have them reversed?
No?
All right.
Let's try that one.
OK.
All right.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, does anyone
else want to try?
Apparently we have
very unbreakable glass.
Maybe we've invented
something new here at MIT.
The sledgehammer?
Oh, that's a great idea.
No.
But there's a reason for it.
Because, see, what we're going
to learn is that baseballs
aren't the only way-- even
though this is Boston,
the Red Sox--
it's not the only
way to break glass.
Now, I don't know what's
going on with this one.
This is tempered.
That means that
it's been treated.
It's been treated
so that it's got
super strong mechanical
strength this way.
You saw that it didn't break.
Of course, neither did that.
But when a glass is
tempered, as we'll realize,
it has to do with
putting certain chemistry
inside the glass,
ions, that are bigger,
that causes a strain
in the material, that
tighten the surface.
And so there's all
this stress built up,
and it's all at the very edge.
So this part is
super, super strong.
But this part, just
a simple little tap--
I didn't even-- I
barely even touched it.
And so that is--
now, so the moral
of that story is
glass might be stronger than
you think, I guess, in this one.
And also, don't tap
the edges of glass,
especially if it's tempered.
Because that's what makes it so
tough on this on the surface.
But the strain builds up.
And if you relieve it with
just a tiny, little tap, boom.
Now, where were we?
Discussion topics--
crystal versus glass,
ordered versus disordered,
substitutional dopants.
That's how to temper glass.
That's what's in
your iPhone glass.
And of course, the Red
Sox, which are on tonight.
And you should watch game three.
Now, the thing about
these peaks is that these
are called characteristic.
And what's nice about them is,
in fact, that no matter what,
they only depend--
I don't care how much
energy I send in.
These peaks only depend
on the metal atom.
So Ronten put in a metal, and
he'd always get the same peaks
if I give it enough energy.
Maybe I don't have enough
energy to excite anything
from down here.
Then you don't get these peaks.
You still get
Bremsstrahlung, but you don't
get the characteristic peaks.
They're called characteristic
because they're
characteristic of the metal.
Now they're dependent
on the chemistry.
If I put in different
metal in, I'm
going to get different Peaks
And so with these
two types of X-rays,
I've got a new kind of light
that I can shine on materials.
I've got a new kind of
light that I can shine.
And the light-- when I
plot it all together,
it might look something like
this where maybe these are
the peaks--
uh oh.
OK.
Maybe these are the peaks
due to going down to K,
and these are the ones
due to going down to L.
So those are K, and these are
L. and the rest is continuous,
and they're on
top of each other.
And I get it all.
But with that new kind of
light, I can do new things.
And that's very important.
And that's what we're going
to do after the exam, which
is on Monday.
The exam.
Don't forget about the exam.
You're doing all
these activities.
You've got to think
about the exam.
Why is this important?
This is important
because we will
be shining x-rays as a source
of light onto crystals.
And there's a very
important thing
that happens when you
shine light onto something.
And you can see it here.
Light is a wave.
Light is a particle.
Have that discussion too.
But here we're looking at it
as a wave, and waves diffract.
That means that they can add
or cancel each other, right
like water waves.
But it depends on
the size of the thing
they're interacting with.
If the size of the thing
they're interacting with
is the same as the
wavelength of light,
then you can get a
diffraction pattern.
And so when we
shine X-rays, which
have wavelengths
that are the same
as the spacing between
planes in a crystal,
well, then it interacts.
And it can diffract.
And that allows us to determine
the structure of the crystal.
That's called X-ray diffraction.
And this is how it all started.
It started with the
Bragg father and son
pair, who actually
said in their paper
the crystal is, in fact, acting
as a diffraction grating.
And from that, you can literally
tell us which kind of crystal
it is.
I want to point
something out here.
That's a father and son.
They both won the Nobel Prize
together for this discovery.
Now, I'm not putting
pressure on you guys.
I'm just saying it's
not all about the kids.
The parents got to step up too.
So that's Bragg defraction.
And that is one of the most--
X-ray diffraction--
what we're going
to do with these powerful
sources of light,
this is one of the
most important ways
to characterize
crystals that we have.
And just as a reminder,
I mentioned the exam.
Don't forget-- this is
what we're talking about.
These planes--
notice the negative.
Remember the 1, 1 bar?
Don't forget about
negative directions.
These are the things that
we're diffracting off of,
literally the crystal planes.
So just a reminder not
to forget about that.
But I can't end by
talking about exam one,
so I have to end
with something happy.
And bubbles always
make us happy, always.
I love blowing bubbles.
I always will.
I always have.
But we don't just blow
bubbles in this class.
We don't just blow bubbles.
We really blow bubbles.
And so what we're
going to do is we're
going to show you how
we like to blow bubbles.
You want to do this?
You go ahead.
Now, what we like to do
is we like to really blow
bubbles in this class.
And so we're going to
use exothermic reactions
to blow bubbles.
And I think that's
really a good way--
you go ahead.
You go ahead.
You're the one.
All right.
That's the only way
to blow bubbles.
That's combining an exothermic
reaction with bubbles.
That's happiness right
there in a bottle.
That is happiness.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, yes, and look at this--
success.
Success.
The power of the hydrogen bond.
OK.
I hope you guys have
a fantastic weekend,
and I hope you enjoy
yourselves and follow
some of these discussions.
[APPLAUSE]